my heart goes out to you I know it's
like to stand helpless while you lose
the ones you love I Know You're angry
but you're letting it go soon oh very
nice I'm happy to meet even you have
such pretty hair think you should have
it styled oh I'm sure you're right would
you like a tour of that what did she
think she wants to share around her
farmhouse she's proud of it I think do
they keep animals inside how do you know
I went to prison it's really quite
simple statistical analysis is what I do
here's the deal one out of three black
men will find themselves incarcerated
during their lifetime you know what let
me give you my statistical analysis you
goin to San Quentin there's a hundred
percent chance that you're gonna be
somebody's [ __ ] Oh what for are you did
this I am booth I know what you want yo
can I come into the out now no you
cannot come into the out now but I can
you are just having to take away the
piece of wood owning a dad for my beer
you're running on time the chute is
guided by GPS you don't have to do
anything
gosh I'm already on it hey man listen
I'm sorry to let y'all down okay i'ma go
ahead and stay up here now brother I'm
sorry to let you down
ah